there's a whole other world of internet
journalism that is media coverage that
is generated and I wanted to ask
especially as someone who was trained as
a journalist what's your view
probably having things a pretty unique
perspective on how would you cover it
now
yes it's oh I have very mixed feelings
about all over there Game of Thrones is
covered by a number of media outlets my
probably like 20 of them at this point
on a week-by-week basis I mean an
episode comes out and on Sunday night
and by Tuesday we have 20 reviews of
that episodes from Entertainment Weekly
and you know the the Waterman quoted in
The New York Times and and you know on
and on there's a whole bunch of them
that are reviewing us episode by episode
recapping the episodes and then hundreds
of people commenting on the episode it's
a really an incredible level of
attention you know when I was a younger
and growing up I mean nobody with you
television shows or if they did review
television shows they review you know TV
God would run a one-page review of the
Dick Van Dyke Show and they would like
to be covering the entire show how old
is it a funny pretty funny show when
Dick Van Dyke is good
they're wondering is this intense
analysis every episode and that's great
I mean most of your viewers are are
terrific
actually as some of them are very
perceptive I mean Moe Ryan they things
on music I can never say his name not to
coin the term second position and you
know several a hipper of Entertainment
Weekly all excellent and I look forward
to seeing what they have to say about
the shows as they come out and we're
fortunate that we're one of the handful
of shows that are covered like this you
know madman was covered the same way
Breaking Bad is covered the same way
and that's great but stepping back and
taking off my guy who does Game of
Thrones and putting on my journalism
critic hat I can't help but feel there's
also vastly unbalanced because terror
this is the golden evening television
there are lots of terrific color is
doing out there this is a show filming
instead of a quote man acting that's the
support of no one is paying Manhattan is
under the Tetra known as reviewing the
name like this no one is reviewing I
mean console shows on the network the
only one that gets any event Good Wife
and that gets nominated for Emmys but
there are lots of other good shows so
it's like a feast or famine thing in
this in this world of internet
journalism even in handy maybe one of my
gifts is a writer but also as a human
being as abilities to the other side so
I'm very glad our show is one of the
ones have been blessed but I can't help
but sing what if I was one of the shows
where I was doing all this great work
and nobody was paying anything whatever
it would drive me crazy do it drive me
crazy
that's half the answer now
[Music]
getting aside of reviewing the shows is
the general quality of internet
journalism in general in fact more and
more as I experienced it more and more
advocates employee
it's a pulling in big you know I
whatever it is
journalistic standards I've learned her
at the Medill certainly doesn't seem to
apply on the internet anymore I think I
must fall victim by the things that I
say when I read about them on these
internet quick things and you know
they're outrageous headlines and taking
things I've said or there's some times I
think they make it up out of whole wall
I mean I I read stories about myself
I've never I know I've never even talked
in person or said anything wait how is
this story coming from there it is it's
getting thousands of clicks and views
and I'm having to do other interviews
where I have to answer what I supposedly
said you know extenders for this
internet thing whatever
[Music]
you know they always like I know my
friends and all solver know about it
people overseas know about it what you
feel about the global impact of it you
know it's huge
overly it's it's you know the most
successful college viewers we've had I
mean I think it's shown like The
Sopranos probably was a bigger hit
domestically or at least was and maybe
that's not even that's not true anymore
but in the first game of Thrones has
outperformed The Sopranos and other
shows internationally and even Emmy
winning shows like Mad Men and Breaking
Bad
you know terrific shows they don't
perform that well internationally
compared to what we've done and I've
reflected on why is that I think there's
a certain universality to fantasy I mean
as great a show it's the front of was
it's a show about a guy in New Jersey
what swords and kings and Dragons and
magic I mean these are these are legends
that are common to many cultures
throughout the world virtually every
civilization that we know pass through a
period where there were kings of lords
and people fighting with swords and
contending for predominance of trynna
straight Napoli's thanks and legends of
dragons occur in and
different cultures so I think that gives
us a certain university to make your
translate very well into other languages
the books themselves are in more than 40
languages now and including some fairly
startling ones I mean that I said some
of the Mongolian recently okay pretty
cool and we signed an IRA gave it so
they'll be in Gaelic and you know or all
my earlier books have a question
translated into the usual usual courts
here - Italian and Spanish but to get
into these these other countries all
around the world this is amazing